what's up guys so as you guys already
know in tow slate at Z 392 come up
during the second half of 2018 but what
is a Z 390 what will it do how much will
it cost and should you buy it
well Z 390 is expected to be built for a
new Intel i7 CPU that is part of isolate
and supposed to have 8 cores and 16
threads it's about time that Intel
brings an octa-core CPU to the
mainstream lineup
considering that by the time that Intel
comes out with the CPU empty would have
had their original 3 octa-core aizen
CPUs up on a market for over a year so
what can we expect in terms of clock
speed
well Intel is well known for providing a
really great clock speed for example
Intel was able to bring up the 8700 K
without any downfalls and clock speed as
long as you overclock when compared to
the 7700 K they could book quite
reasonably overclocked all the way to 5
gigahertz and that is in my opinion all
you really need
so as a result it would be very
impressive and ideal if the 9700 K or
whatever it will be called is able to
comfortably overclocked to 5 gigahertz
as well just imagine that 8 cores and 16
threads at its solid 5 gigahertz that
would be great and an absolute monster
with those types of speeds
Intel would absolutely dominate the
mainstream market as the overwhelmingly
best gaming CPU available at that point
Rison would unfortunately not be the
best at any scale of performance however
they will still most likely be the value
King and Intel will accentuate their
position as the performance scheme even
if Intel isn't able to squeeze out 5
gigahertz out of their new CPU they'll
almost most certainly be able to push
out to the mid to high for get hurt
overclock and that itself will
established themselves as the best
mainstream CPU so obviously this CPU is
seeming to be an absolute monster but
should you wait for it and should you
buy it this
EU is expected to be produced in the 10
nanometer process so that's a plus but
is that all worth the price there really
is no clear price point yet but I would
expect the chip to be easily priced at
four hundred to four hundred fifty
dollars in tow can even get away with
more not to mention the extra price the
Zee 390 motherboards as opposed to the Z
370 motherboards so it definitely will
be available only for a premium price
the performance is worth it right well
first of all I don't think any average
or even enthusiast really needs that
much power only professionals and only
some professionals really need that
performance under less I know that many
of you guys can't wait to get your hands
on this ship so should you pull the
trigger if you want the best and you
can't settle for anything else other
than the best then I don't even know why
err washing this foreign to video but
it's not the ITA say will change your
mind about buying this and there's
nothing wrong with that either because
it truly will be an awesome CPU even if
it is a bit overkill if you're a gamer
looking for performance this CPU won't
really help you sure it may provide you
with a few extra frames per second but
honestly I think that you should just go
with the 8700 K or even 8600 care or
7700 K because those will provide you
with almost a sim gaming performance and
it'll also save you some cash as for
productivity users who are looking to
get the CPU it's really up to you this
CPU will save some time on your Premiere
Pro exports in a few seconds here and
there but again I don't really think
it'll be enough to justify the extra
price so really if you have some extra
cash then sure go for it
but otherwise the 8700 K or any other
high-end CPU will serve you just fine so
guys what do you think about these
upcoming CPUs from Intel and do you
think that it's worth it
what clock speed do you think it will
deliver and do you think AMD is
something better in store with rise in
to be sure to comment down below what
you guys think I read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think but that's all I have for you guys
this time if you guys liked this video
then make sure to drop a like on this
video and hit that subscribe button if
you love this video
see more videos just like this and it
does benefit as well if you want to be
notified every time I post a new video
but until next video
[Music]